any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic today it's
a great honor to have on zoobi his
impresario of mind in the body and we
met kind of tangentially I think I was
sort of like an opening act for zoobi in
that I was on the bench Bureau Sunday
special I think a week before he was and
so together I think you and i zu be
teamed up for 1 million 1000 views I
won't say I won't say what I what part
of that 1 million 1000 I contributed to
but it might be the thousand
anyway zoobi welcome where were you
today where's your studio at today I'm
reporting from Southampton UK right now
Oh wonderful so zoobi you're the author
of a book that I got the minute I I saw
that it existed it's called strong
advice and I always like to start off my
conversations with authors such as
yourself by a little dive into the book
and I always note the advice that people
give to not judge a book by its cover
I think that that's misgiven I think you
should judge your book by your cover in
a certain sense especially when it's
interesting and intriguing so I'm
showing it here on the video for those
of you I'm gonna click get rid of me so
you can see somebody who's actually able
to to make a pose like this I always say
thank you for your book because you know
it allowed me to mm-hmm to drop a couple
of pounds you know for my double chin to
my stomach so I dropped it all the way
down tastic yeah so to walk us through
the cover zoobi what does it mean and
what is the title and how did you come
up with the title subtitle etc oh wow
okay so the cover is a is me looking
jacked that was actually that was
actually a picture from an album
photoshoot but I never used it with the
album or anything so I thought you know
that would actually make her a pretty
cool a pretty cool cover so that's why I
used that specific photo and of course I
wanted to ya show myself in in good
physical condition if I'm promoting and
selling a fitness book then I think it's
imperative that I practice what I preach
and
I am in good shape some people said it
looks like like a woman's romance novel
or something which I find quite funny
and in terms of the title I have to give
props to um III would shout out the
specific handle but I'm not sure off the
top of my head but uh somebody on
Twitter actually recommended title I was
saying that when I was writing it I was
saying hey I'm writing a fitness book
thinking of ideas for titles etc and
someone someone tweeted strong advice at
me and I was like you know what that is
that's actually a fantastic title so I
ended up using that and that's how it
became strong advice and then zoo bees
guide to fitness for everybody that's
just a little tag line to make it clear
that it's a fitness book and also that
it's for everybody because I do get a
lot of people asking you know does this
work for younger people is it does it
work for women does it work for people
over 50 etc and it's I the answer is yes
the principles that I lay out in the
book and the advice I give in there is
not super specific to young men for
example it's um whether you're a young
man or a more elderly woman then a lot
of it will be applicable to you some of
the exercise sections some of that may
need to be modified a little bit in
terms of the recommended exercises and
sets and reps and things like that but
in terms of the foundational info
it's very Universal and yeah I look at
it and the first thing I always think
about when I when I read books about
fitness and I think I've read every
single book there is about fitness not
that you could tell but you know first I
look at the person I say you know I look
at his ubi I look at the cover and I say
you know is it true the rumors are true
that you were born when you were born
you had a six-pack on your umbilical
cord like is yours is your DNA your
destiny essentially as are you basically
are human beings effectively at the
limitations of what their physical genes
for building muscle and losing weight
etc no in one word we all have you know
we all have different levels of
potential we all have different
strengths in
weaknesses etc but most people never
even come remotely close to their
potential and you certainly in terms of
physical fitness and strength and health
etc you don't know what your genetic
potential is unless you've been training
effectively and eating well for probably
at least four to five years you're not
even gonna have a clue um right for
anyone who thinks I came out the womb
looking like that no I mean I weighed
more when I was 16 then I weigh now at
33 okay so and anyone who knew I used to
be overweight right I was overweight I
was I was a chubby kid I used to I used
to take me like 12 minutes to run a mile
I couldn't do a pull-up until I was I
think I did my first pull-up when I was
13 or 14 I was not some jacked ripped
child whatsoever I think I probably have
stronger than average I think I'm
stronger than average in terms of my
genetic potential certainly in terms of
lifts like my deadlift I think he there
are a lot of people know who no matter
how much they trained they probably
wouldn't get that deadlift over 600
pounds which I've done but I wouldn't
have even known that had I not put in
ten plus years of training so genetics
are a really lame excuse for success in
anything I mean that's I can't think of
anything that's more defeatist than
saying I you can't succeed in something
because of your genetics sure if you're
talking about the very tip-top optimal
levels right you're talking about being
a professional or world-class in
something sure that's going to play a
role not everybody can no matter how
hard you train not everybody's gonna be
a professional NBA player not everyone's
gonna be a professional football player
rugby player etc right and genetics are
going to play a role there as long as
well as work ethic but in terms of
rising to maybe the top 10 or top 20
percent of most things most people have
the possibility to do that with training
and determination and perseverance
some people may get there quicker than
others it may be a little bit easier for
some people than others but um
yeah I absolutely do not think that DNA
is destiny not not in the slightest I
don't believe that now talk me through
your philosophy on kind of knowledge
versus wisdom kind of in the application
of the tools and the tactics you bring
about in the book it's very prescriptive
it's it's very its formulaic which is
good I'm not saying in a negative way
because it's I think people at the last
resort rely on their willpower and you
know kind of at the first resort that
rely on rituals religious rituals or
whatever those are very hard to break
and in the middle is kind of like habits
but you know what's your perspective on
that I've heard people like Jocko
willing saying you know don't rely on
willpower it's nonsense or no willpower
on the other hand can be the greatest
strongest
trait that a human being can have where
do you cleave in that spectrum of
kind of hierarchy of what you should
rely on mmm it's a good question I mean
I think that what I say in the book is
that motivation gets you started and
habit keeps you going
so I think when it comes to nutrition
and training and other positive habits
it's important to make lifestyle changes
it's important to make long-term
habitual changes rather than just
thinking okay I'm gonna go on a diet for
four weeks or I'm gonna go to the gym
for two weeks or whatever it is it's
important to overhaul your entire way of
thinking so that you think about it long
term I mean I'm thinking 30 years down
the line 40 years down the line 50 years
down the line right I'm not gonna stop
going to the gym I'm not gonna stop
taking my nutrition seriously at any
point in my linh my lifetime I've
decided I've committed to that and yeah
sure there may be some times where I'm
able and I'm able to give it 10% more
and there's times where I might have to
cut back a little bit etc but it's
really a long-term habitual change
because you know what to get going on
something yes it takes a level of
motivation it takes a level of willpower
especially if it's something that you
are not used to so even within the world
of fitness for example I am not
particularly fun fond of running like I
certainly don't like
long distance running so if I want to
develop a running habit and I want to
work on my cardiovascular fitness and
just get better at running a couple
miles then it's gonna take me is I need
willpower and motivation to get going on
that I don't need motivation and
willpower at the stage to lift weights
and do strength training because I've
been doing it for over 15 years I enjoy
it I love it I know exactly what I'm
doing etc and I'm good at it and it's
also just part of my it's part of my
habits at least it was prior to lock
down so I'm still doing my training so
in order to develop any new habit
especially one that takes effort and
where there might be a little bit of
pain and discomfort and it takes it
takes willpower it takes motivation to
do that but the thing that's gonna keep
you going in the long term if you still
want to be doing that same thing a year
from now you do have to ultimately form
the habit because as strong as your
willpower may be and is motivated as you
may be if you don't form the habit you
know after a certain amount of time you
are almost destined to fall off it as
other things get busy as other things
take priority
those things will override the things
that have a lower priority so what
people need to do if they want to get
healthier is put their health at a
higher priority then they do some of the
other things in in their lives
essentially because that's how we all
operate whether or not it's consciously
we were always weighing things up in
terms of priority and when people say
they don't have time that's the most
common excuse you'll hear for anything
right I don't have time and when someone
says that what you're really saying is
that that thing is not a it's not a high
priority for me right now that's really
what that's really the translation of
the statement and hey I say that too
lots of times right I say that too
depending on what the issue is and all
I'm saying is yeah you know I could I
could do it right we all have the same
amount of time but there are other
things that are a higher priority to me
right now
rightly I wrongly yeah I see that you
know I heard one someone asks like
Arnold Schwarzenegger you know my my
former governor here and they said you
know like well you just have this
advanced Genet
and he was like now I have the same
number of muscles as you do you know
it's like we're all born with these you
know for the most part born with the
same potential and then as how do you
actualize your potential
I wonder before we segue into kind of
compare and contrast and you know not
the trash talk other diet or fitness
plans but I do want to just segue just
very briefly into but what does a
typical day look like you for for for
zoobi now versus before lockdown so to
speak what what kind of you know are you
super early riser do you just start
lifting like a machine what and then
what does your nutrition look like not
super deep we don't have to go yeah and
ten minutes on this but just kind of
big-picture overview what does your day
look like to think yeah right now
everything is shifted back later so
right now I am waking up and going to
sleep later than I normally would and do
so at the moment I'm probably going to
bed at like realistically maybe 1 a.m.
on average and getting up around I don't
know 8:00 8:30 or something normally
that would be shifted earlier so I'd
normally be waking up around 7:00 and
going to bed a little bit earlier but
yeah I mean a typical day I will I will
get up I'll normally um you know clean
myself up brush my teeth etc and then
normally do some form of training
whether that's bodyweight training
push-ups pull-ups single leg squats etc
or go and or go for a run normally I'll
run for like about 20-25 minutes or so I
am trying to get into the into the
running habit while we are in this
period because like I said I don't like
running which is why I need to do it
more
I believe in constantly pushing yourself
outside of your comfort zone and doing
things sometimes that you that you don't
like because you know it is good is good
for you and and you've got to do it and
like I said before I need to practice
what I preach so I can't just do the
things that are easy for me are already
within my current set of habits if I
know that it's good for me then it's
important for me to to adopt that and
work to add that to what I'm already
doing in terms of
prior to lockdown like I said normally I
would wake up earlier and just get
changed and hit the gym straightaway and
just get into my get into my training
which is primarily based around strength
training but also a little bit of cardio
in terms of my eating patterns again it
shifted back a bit later I'm still
typically doing a light version of
intermittent fasting I'm not SuperDuper
strong on it as much as I normally would
be I'm probably at the moment on average
yeah eating window.i I mean I still work
to keep it around eight hours sometimes
it might go up to ten and be like
normally it would be an eight-hour
eating window and then 16 hour fast at
the moment it might be more like a 10
hour eating window and and sorry about
14 hour fast something like that but
what I'm trying to do right now really
is about maintenance I'm trying to
maintain and make sure I don't lose too
much muscle make sure I don't gain too
much fat and just overall stay healthy
both physically and and psychologically
that's really what I'm trying to do I'm
not expecting to make huge gains without
having having gym access but um yeah you
know I'm hanging in there this is the
longer this is the longest I've gone
without going to the gym since I started
training but how long just I've ever
gone yeah hopefully it'll it'll be
ending soon be back in the gym so
speaking of you know programs I heard it
said once you know if knowledge and lack
of knowledge were the issue you know and
all you needed was knowledge then
everyone would be a billionaire with
six-pack abs and and I wonder you know
your take is different actually and
unique compared to a lot of other plans
you know there's taketo I just went
through a list of all the diets I tried
you know this weekend you know
intermittent fasting keto paleo doing
supplements bulletproof diet when you're
just like all fat you know then there's
diet supplements where do you you know
fit in on there is is it people should
try all these different things from Tim
Ferriss to Dave Asbury to Peter attea
where do you kind of come down on that
and that realm or do you think basically
the advice is just simple
calories in calories out exercise burns
more energy than you take in what do you
make of the proliferate I so many
guidebooks yeah of course yeah I mean
I'm I I'm pretty boring in that sense
I'm typically averse to fads I don't
like the fads in anything right if
everyone is doing something and it's got
like a certain brand name and it's just
this or whatever like I I become
naturally quite skeptical and also I
don't like the idea of unless someone
has something like an autoimmune
disorder or like a serious intolerance
or allergy or something I'm not a big
fan personally certainly for my own
eating of eliminating entire food groups
I don't like the idea of totally you
know going SuperDuper low-fat or super
duper low-carb or cutting out all sugars
or cutting out all fruit or all
vegetables or just eating meat etc you
know not eating meat at all I don't like
any extremist approach to dieting I mean
if that works for you and you're happy
with it and you enjoy those foods and
it's effective etc that's totally fine I
mean I'm I'm an omnivore like I'm just
an omnivore I'm not plant-based I'm not
carnivore I'm not I'm not paleo I'm just
I'm just like I just I eat I primarily
based my foods around whole nutritious
foods you know stuff that my ancestors
would at least recognize for the most
part even then you know I'd be a liar if
I said I don't eat processed food I'd be
a liar if I said I don't eat you know
sugars and I don't eat simple carbs and
stuff like that I do it's not my it's
not my primary it's not the primary sort
of core component of my diet but every
single day I have some sugar every
single day I have some processed food
pretty much but it's a relatively small
percentage and I know with me as long as
I keep my as long as I keep my calories
in check I keep my protein high keep my
carbs and fats within reasonable amounts
then I personally do fine you know if
some people find they need to cut
something out and that works really well
for them then I don't oppose it you know
I'm generally I'm very much in the camp
of look if it works for you if it works
for you then do it right if someone is
on a plant-based diet and they're
serving
they're thriving in their vitamin b12
and vitamin D levels and iron etc are
all fine and they're healthy and their
blood work is good and they like it and
they enjoy it I'm not gonna be trying to
convert them to you know start eating
meat
similarly if someone is only eating meat
and all those things are good I'm not
gonna be like trying to force them to
eat add fruit to it or to add you know
vegetables or carbs etc if that works
for you then that is that is totally
fine and I think people get too too
dogmatic in this enough because it's not
that you know like what what you eat
literally does not make me crap pardon
the departed to be crude but I thought
you were a clean wrapper Zuba the most
yeah I did censor it a little I said
crap right but like in the and and like
literally in this sense right like when
someone else puts in their body what
they eat does not have any impact on me
whatsoever so yes I do encourage people
to pay attention to their nutrition and
I encourage people to train I encourage
people to be healthy and realize they
only have one body so they'd better take
care of it yeah but um in terms of the
prescription I'm happy to be flexible in
that regard and understand that just
because something works ideally for me
it doesn't mean it's gonna be optimal
for for the next person yeah there are
certain basic rules that matter and
which is what I highlight in the book
certain things that we need to be aware
of but then beyond that it's it's
totally fine and healthy to have some
flexibility there so I want to get your
opinions on kind of the next set of talk
topics we'll cover kind of the brain
mind side of zubi and creativity
imagination that were known for here in
San Diego we're the r3c Clark center for
human imagination and one of the things
I've gotten into lately is talking to
thinkers medical doctors Peter Diamandis
and dr. Judson Brewer and other people
about the impact of the brain and kind
of the mind machine interface and the
first thing I want to ask you is what do
you make of the proliferation of
meditation and mindfulness things like
that I notice your fellow rapper Puff
Daddy has a new meditation course out
that you can enjoy yeah so you know is
that
that we're kind of getting getting you
know it's getting too popular or I mean
to you where do you view the role of
meditation and mindfulness in the in the
pursuit of physical change it's a good
question
I don't really meditate I don't notice
it I've had um a lot it's actually a
question I get asked a lot I think a lot
of people assume that I'm I'd be a
meditation guy I'm not I haven't done it
before I've tried it before
um and I'll probably try it and get into
it at some point again in the future
but um again I don't I don't do trends
right I mean I don't if it works for
somebody didn't do it if and if
meditation is good for you and you find
it helpful and you find it centers you
and balances you etc then I'm not gonna
knock it I'm not gonna say hey
meditation is is bad or I think it's
silly or that I just if it works for you
then that is totally fine the times I
have done it and have gotten into it I
haven't particularly found that it's
made a big difference for me I mean I'm
someone who's very already very low
stress very low anxiety isn't super up
in my emotions and stuff and you know I
may be for someone who is more anxious
or is more likely more prone to certain
mental health situations and things like
that then it's much more beneficial for
them but um yeah that's kind of my
thought on there in terms of mindfulness
I mean I guess it depends us
specifically what you mean by that
but anything it could be prayer it could
be okay yeah no no yeah I mean I
certainly pray every day and that can be
considered my own form of meditation
maybe but it's kind of just a more
traditional version of it and and that
certainly helps to send to me and to
give me perspective and gratitude on a
daily basis and also just yeah
put up to God the things that I'm
worried about and things that I'm
grateful for etc but ya know I'm a big
fan of mindfulness in assuming that is
the opposite of mindlessness right you
know not being conscious and not being
aware of what you're doing and what
you're saying
and all of that I think it's important
to be mindful in general I think we
should be you know you don't want to be
Thoth you don't wanna be totally caught
up in yourself and worrying and not
being able to articulate yourself or say
and do things because you're so worried
about how other people may interpret it
or how it may come across or what the
repercussions may be etc I think that's
taking it too far but um it's certainly
good to understand who you are know your
personality know your proclivities know
your strengths your weaknesses if you
have any things that you may be prone to
be addicted you know get addicted to or
any negative habits or things you may
have then it's good to be conscious of
those and I certainly am like I'm very
very conscious of my strengths and my
weaknesses and I'm super aware of how I
can come across to people rightly or
wrongly I mean even if I weren't like I
get so much feedback on everything I I
do now and everything I say now that um
that seems to be the case that I sort of
have to and that's to be honest that
that's something that can be a little
bit of a stress these days just because
I'm not used to so many people caring
about what I think no it's weird like
it's cool it's cool in a way but at the
same time it's weird I mean so many
conversations and arguments and debates
and whatever I've had over the past few
months have been with you know people
you know could even be loved ones who
think I should say things in a certain
way or think I should think this or I
should phrase it like that or whatever
and I'm kind of like look I'm me you
know right I can take I can take
feedback on board
sometimes I'll listen to it I'll always
listen to it and sometimes I will agree
with it and accept it other times I will
disagree and reject it but ultimately
I'm like look I'm being me I'm being
honest I'm being authentic I'm being
truthful to myself I'm not just saying
things to you know start crap or Alvar
all people up and trying to get people
to think trying to get people to
recognize their potential I'm trying to
get people to you know question and
challenge certain beliefs I'm trying to
empower people I'm trying to encourage
people and that mostly comes across
there are some people who don't get it
or it may it may take them a while to
get it or they might
like the way I've said something or the
message but look you can't please
everybody
you really cannot please everybody and
attempting to is going to make you a
very sad person right and and that's
true the bigger your voice is I mean in
some some in some ways I miss when no
one cared what I thought yeah exactly
it's funny I know what I mean like I
miss when no one cared what I thoughts
in a way cuz it's like I can just say
something and I don't have to worry
about you know getting thousands of
responses and then sometimes even
getting phone calls and emails and stuff
of having to explain myself all the time
it's just like this is what I was the
famous scene in Animal Farm were you
know Benjamin the donkey I think the
paid character talks to Benjamin the
donkey and says you know you've got such
an awesome tail the aren't you aren't
you lucky and Benjamin says the good
Lord gave me a tail to keep away the
Flies but I'd rather not have the Flies
and not need the tail I kind of I kind
of can relate to that I mean I had one
of my sons he was upstairs you know or
just hanging out recorded getting ready
to record him like you want to say hi to
zoobi he loves her music he's a huge fan
Gers no I don't want to be famous you
don't have to be on screen maybe I'll
get a mouse comedy we're done but how
does that how does that this this rise I
mean it hasn't been you know sudden in
the sense because I kind of see you as a
overnight sensation that's been 5 10
years in the making you've been this
workman you know slowly building up this
brand and it's a mental brand it's a
physical brand most people are lucky if
they have half a brain you know are
they're known for you're known for so
much do you ever because you can't train
to be like a personality or a podcast
house you know there's no there's no
major and we want I want to get into
your to your formal academic studies in
a bit but you know do you ever feel like
you know it's a very common phrase and
academia imposter syndrome like I'm not
really good enough like everyone else is
smarter than me and the higher you go
the higher the echelon you're at the
more honed and finely tuned the
competition is you know as you rise in
academia you're competing it's people
that have been literally I've been in
academia I've been you know this is my
44th year of school
you know I'm never left school and I'm
with people that have been here for
decades as well and how do you do you
ever have that do you ever have that
kind of inkling notion of anxiety maybe
I maybe I'm not that good or or do you
not do you just have this you know kind
of preternatural ability to just say
like God put me here or whoever put me
here and I'm on this mission and I'm
gonna accomplish it
the latter no I don't I don't get
impostor syndrome not if I'm not if I'm
doing something that I you know how to
do maybe I get impostor syndrome if I
was doing something that I was super you
know not rehearsed in and and haven't
done before and I'm not good at it and I
don't have the capability if it's
something that I'm confident about then
then no um no I've got an extreme level
of confidence for things that are within
my wheelhouse and within Mike within my
comfort zone and that's that's totally
fine for me and you know I like to you
know like I said I mean the tricky part
is just dealing with you know handl
handling feedback that's probably the
that's probably the hardest part I mean
I've worked for a very long time for
people to care about what I think you
know at the same time on one hand it's
like hey you know I don't want to
complain about people caring about what
I think this is what I've worked for and
I've just specifically gone out of my
way to give build my audience and build
my platform etc but at the same time
it's just so hard to you know there are
so many voices both positive and
negative I mean most is positive by the
way like 9 out of 10 people who follow
me and see what I write etc and listen
to my music and listen to my podcast
vast majority of them do that because
they like me and even if they don't
hundred percent agree with me on
everything they know that I'm honest
they know that I'm authentic they know
that I'm being true to myself and I'm
not sort of playing - I'm not playing to
any given crowd right it's why I'm very
careful to stay away from identifying as
as some you know a follower of some
political party or some movement or
whatever like I'm free-floating so
can't be held hostage I can't be held to
ransom by any particular group or
organization or whatever it is if I
don't toe certain party lines and that's
that's powerful that actually puts me an
extremely powerful position because
there are very few people who can do
that the amount of messages emails etc I
get every single day from people who are
telling me like hey man like I love what
you're doing although you're saying like
I don't know if I would be able to do it
but know that I agree with you and I'm
supporting you and you know keep going
kind of thing and and it's like okay
cool so I'm not um I mean I don't
it's weird I mean I never knew that my
thoughts and my way of thinking were
particularly interesting hmm okay it
wasn't until like 2018 where I started
to kind of talk more about other things
going on in the world rather than just
using channels to promote my music very
directly that I realized like oh okay
maybe I'm maybe I'm in a minority of how
I think I thought that everyone or most
people thought the way I did about
certain things and I very clearly
learned but this is not this is not the
case and as that happens I think that's
a big part of why my audience is just
growing and growing so so rapidly by
thousands every single day now I think
that is happening because people are
hungry for clear thinkers people are
hungry for people who tell the truth
people are hungry for people who are
honest and have values and have
principles and have the courage to sort
of say what they think even if there
might be some backlash from it you know
I never knew that that was anything all
that special and get messages from
people telling me how brave and
courageous etc I am and by my own
measure I don't consider myself like
super brave or super courageous I mean I
think I think soldiers are super
courageous I think people who write out
like firemen who run into burning
buildings to save people are courageous
I think that policemen who risked their
lives every day to keep community safe
for our brave way that's that's my bar
for brave and
you know I tweet something and people
are like oh my gosh I'm like it's a
tweet like I don't care if you save some
if people get mad like okay like you
know not putting my life in danger I'm
yeah I'm not like Bernie you know that's
the thing and I'm like man the bar for
courage the bar for bravery is is kind
of low I'm just here being me and yeah I
don't even share all of my thoughts
there's plenty of thoughts that I think
I want to talk about those thoughts that
you know you might not get out but you
know behind me is a picture of an MRI
machine and I used to kind of scan the
brains of people and and see what they
you know functionally are their brain
different regions are firing when they
when they actually are considering music
or art or something like that I want to
ask you does your in your experience has
the you know fitness level that you've
gotten to or the you know healthy you
know kind of living aspect that you're
that you are promoting and that you
embody have has that benefited your
writing your music your creativity is
there a mind-body create like you notice
it or are they basically decoupled and
and you know not really necessarily
interconnected yeah they're definitely
connected you know your mind and your
body are not two totally separate
entities and I mean for people who don't
lift weights for example a lot of people
don't understand that the primary way
that you get stronger is not through
building new muscle it's through
training the muscles that you already
have to fire more efficiently and to be
more effective and to recruit more
fibers here your entire nervous system
which includes your brain and then all
the nerves that run through your body
that is what the mind muscle connection
is so in fact by lifting weights you are
improving your cognitive function these
things are not are not decoupled it's
not um that's why I kind of find it
funny that there's this meathead
stereotype of people who lift weights or
they train and their hair somehow less
intelligent or whatever when in practice
I found actually the opposite and
someone who already is intelligent could
probably be even smarter and sharper if
they did do more physical training and
they did train their body in there
brain and nervous systems to be better
connected let alone the endorphins and
the the stamina benefits and all the
other benefits that you gain so and I
mean I see this at a small level
sometimes so for example if I am stuck
creatively then exercise often helps me
to get unstuck I'm sure some people have
witnessed this is before right that
you'd probably get a lot of their
interesting ideas when they're going for
a walk or when they're cycling or when
they're doing something else and it
sparks it sparks creativity it sparks
ideas it sparks conversations etc
whereas if you just lie in bed all day
you'll probably find you're not that
creative so I don't know the exact
mechanism through which that happens
physiologically but um yeah I think most
people are aware of the the sort of the
power of the even that half hour walk
just you know whether you're you're
doing some writing or you're working on
an essay or you're studying etc just
going for a walk you'll come back with a
clearer head and perhaps some new ideas
and I look at you and I think and your
work not just physically but I think
about you know this notion of
cross-training which you know became
popular when I was a kid but also you
know the notion that there's
cross-training inter you know inter body
system as well in other words you
cross-training your your body you
cross-training your brain and there are
these interconnections I want to talk a
little bit about about your unique
perspective on life that you gleaned I
mean you live in so many different
places around the world you've been
involved in different cultures and
different and different activities and
one of the places I'm not mistaken was
Oxford where I believe you studied
computer science isn't that is that
correct yeah that's correct you yeah so
at Oxford is one of my close mentors and
friends Sir Roger Penrose and he's the
rouse ball professor emeritus of
mathematics he had you know perhaps more
than any other person the greatest
influence on my mind if you will on the
on the way that I thought as a young
scientist and it really inspired me to
both want to become a scientist and and
also to become a popular science author
as I later did and the I was on
by his endorsement on my book losing the
Nobel Prize became endorsed the lead
endorsement is by none other than Sir
Roger Penrose and he's been into the
arthur c-- clark center many times now
the emperor's new mind which was his
famous book from the 1989 it's now and
it's uh and and i can't believe it's
going on its fourth decade it's over
thirty years old
and that book really proposed and
explained for the first time this notion
of we know whether or not computers
could think and whether or not
consciousness was something that was
physically manifest or whether it was
whether there was something you know
ethereal that we literally could not put
our hands on and one of the topics that
he brings up is also from our fellow i
believe he was a Cambridge man so I
don't know if you're entitled to say
anything good about a king but but Alan
Turing and he proposes famous test and
the Turing test is sort of a sort of a
proposal up those are your temporary
tattoos here's the Turing test he can't
really see it but it basically says that
if you put a computer you know that has
an artificial intelligence and secluded
it from a human being and you just had
the human being typing questions into a
terminal could the human being determine
whether or not he or she was talking to
a computer or a human being and if it
could pass that test then it was said
that the artificial intelligence could
could pass the Turing test what I want
to understand from your perspective is
you know are you what do you think about
artificial intelligence and the rise of
computer power and then the second part
is do you think an artificial
intelligence will ever make music as
compelling as music such as yourself Wow
okay I'll answer the second half first
and the the second half is well AI is
already creating a lot of music
particularly in electronic genres
ambient onerous things that don't have
lyrics and melody in terms of human
voices and lyricism and things like that
will an artificial intelligence ever be
able to rap like me I don't think so any
time soon maybe you know in the
SuperDuper future anything is possible I
think
in terms of yeah you know melodies and
harmonies and synthesized music then
yeah it's it's already happening and
it's gonna continue getting better but
in terms of the human ingenuity required
to put together interesting hip-hop
punchlines and stories and puns and
witty lyrics and stuff like that and
deliver it in a human way I hope that
it's never possible mmm I hope that it's
never possible because come this leads
into the first part of the question
which is that I think artificial
intelligence is cool and I think it's
exciting I also think that it's
terrifying mm-hmm no I think that it's
terrifying and well on a lot of levels
on a lot of levels you know I I have a
you know maybe maybe some of this is the
is the religious part of me or the the
conservative part of me but I have a
concern around human beings playing God
too much right like when humans start
doing things like trying to become
immortal or trying to reprogram genetic
codes so people can have designer babies
so that you can choose what I color your
baby will have and how tall they'll be
when they grow up and whether W so they
can have a six-pack like you did on your
umbilical yeah yeah like when humans
start to mess with that stuff or you
know even elements of you know like even
things like what what do they call it
like you know euthanasia and things like
that any anything that comes to humans
playing God I I grow quite weary this
you know or trying to create a new
species or all of that kind of stuff I
find it very unnerving and artificial
intelligence past a certain level also
falls into that with me so for example
you're seeing Pete this crossover
between AI and robotics and people are
making these um you know like sex robots
and stuff like that right which they're
hoping eventually will become so real
and so whatever that people you know
men can have a a virtual girlfriend who
has a physical form and looks like looks
like and feels like and talks like an
actual woman but is in fact a robot all
I just think that's opening a huge
Pandora's box like like a crazy
Pandora's box I think people who are
trying to make human beings immortal
right if because we're not really good
at thinking beyond what sounds
interesting and what sounds enticing and
thinking of what that really would
entail right if human beings were
immortal that would fundamentally change
everything like ever like our entire
reality our entire concept of life our
entire concept of family and education
or everything would totally change like
what what do we do now then do people
still do people still reproduce what do
you do if people really like you're just
opening such a crazy right what do you
what do you do like our entire life is
everything in life individually and
collectively is based on the idea of us
having a certain amount of years on
earth okay so you go to work for so you
go to school for this many decades then
you work for this many decades then you
have some retirement and here's you do
like at this position you learn and then
you earn and you have a family and then
you grow and then you raise and then do
that and then eventually you die okay if
you now let's not even talk about
immortality if you increase the human
lifespan to two hundred years what do
you do in those two hundred years do you
are you a teenager now for like 50 years
right do you just behave like a teenager
for 50 years and then you started like
which which part of that spectrum is the
one that gets the extra you know
lifespan yeah which is the part that
gets the extra 120 year boost is it at
the end is it just like you're just
gonna be really old now or you know
you'll be like an 80 year old but you'll
just be stuck there now for an extra
hundred years or with the part and it'll
be longer and it affects everything and
I just don't think people really in this
scientific excitement a lot of people
don't seem to think about the potential
impact of this yeah right if you did
become if you
did create an AI and you merged it with
robotics and you essentially had what
amounts to a person but it's actually an
artificial intelligence like some some
black mayor thing right so I'm talking
to you right now but you're actually a
robot right you know what about human
rights dude what about rights like do
you now have does that does the AI get
rights guys vote keep them turn it off
turn it on I like it yeah right if you
want if you want to unplug them can they
defend themselves Yeah right like yeah
can you can you all of this stuff is
like these are you know it's not a thing
yet but if they were to go that far
these all become very very legitimate
questions and that just I don't know I
do feel like human curiosity will be the
end of humanity mmm I think it's I I
think I don't know I don't know how
human beings are gonna go extinct but I
think it's going to be self perpetuated
I think we will create something
eventually that like like science will
go so far that they'll create some wet
weather this is a weapon or a virus or
artificial intelligence that goes rogue
or whatever it is it's gonna be
something that human beings and
scientists are gonna create and it's
gonna get totally out of hand and it's
gonna just end up wiping us out right if
you know if you take AI to its level if
you had AI which was smarter than like
literally smarter than people and could
continue to get smarter at a very rapid
rate
like what's to stop them from just
treating us like you know cows or
chickens right they they they become the
superior superior master race and they
might just be like oh maybe we'll keep
humans as pets or maybe we'll just like
get rid of him like we're smarter yeah
I've had Michael Shermer on the show
long ago and he's you know he's famous
for revising or riffing on as you might
say one-up star arthur c clarke famous
laws which was that any sufficiently
advanced civilization is
indistinguishable from magic
our technology is indistinguishable
magic and schirmer's law is any
sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from God and here
is a big atheist but he also he's more a
little more sanguine about AI in that he
says you know he drives a Tesla and you
know it's certainly faster for him to
get to downtown LA if he just you know
drives down the sidewalk and the Tesla
recognizes that that would involve
killing a lot of people even though so a
lot of its optimization you know for a
third metric and I always say you know
these artificial intelligences and
machine learning device of really
intelligent but where do they train on I
mean are you counting like they'll say
oh they can take solve a problem that
would take me you know our human being a
hundred thousand years to solve but I'm
like well but did they also go and get a
PhD for seven years you know today do
they also go through I mean they were
trained by human beings and when once
they get to a level where they can truly
improvise and and and you know create
what we would indistinguishably say is a
creation rather than just pattern
recognition like the ambient trance or
whatever the music you're talking about
before yeah if they can do freestyle if
they can do jazz improvisation I think
those would be you know versions of the
Turing test and you know when they come
out with one that a song that says you
know ok data you know and ok transistor
you know then you then you should worry
but I don't think right now ya know I
don't think right now but you know we
have to keep in mind how quickly stuff
changes man you know I mean my I'm in
you know my 30s and just in my own
lifetime I have seen insane
technological progress there is stuff
that what we are doing right now in 1990
this would have looked like you know
witchcraft right like how are two people
in different countries in real time
being able to see each other being able
to talk to each other on this thing
called the internet and other people can
tune in and listen like all of it like
smart smart phones right the little
smart phones we're carrying in our
pockets every single day if you just
went back 30 years ago and you said yeah
in the future in a couple decades
everyone's going to have this thing and
it we're all connected and you can do
this and you can do that and it has an
HD camera and all of this stuff they
just be like what are you talking about
if you showed people the graphics of
modern computer games
stuff like that so in just another 30
years
we already cannot we already cannot
fathom what its gonna look like in 20
years like there's gonna be something in
20 years which we're not even aware of
in which we're not even thinking about
which everyone is gonna use everyone is
gonna have it you're gonna question how
just like we now wonder like how do we
do this before the internet there's
gonna be like something else that's like
that or other things that are like that
and that's gonna keep happening and
happening and happening and so in terms
of where AI is right now no I'm not
concerned with where it is right now for
the most part but gosh 20 years even let
alone a hundred years let alone 200
years yeah lord knows what kind of stuff
people are going to be coming up with
and I think a very interesting question
ethically regardless of someone's
beliefs is what should what if anything
should be the limits of science hmm
right like are they is there some stuff
that like could be done in science
possibly that we just should not do that
scientists just speaking for my
colleagues you know not only you know my
opinion but but I think that scientists
by our nature are very you know very
childlike and in a good way that we
wonder we are curious we puzzle we like
to solve things but we're also like
children in the badly we're selfish
we're jealous
we're spiteful you know we we have all
the good and you know because that's
what Wonder is right and you're a kid
and you solve the puzzle II solve a
Rubik's Cube door slam do it again and
we also our antennas other turn so I
think you know one of the worst things
to say to a scientist who cannot do that
now that's gotten into trouble and but
it's also been a force for good you know
science I always say means means
knowledge
it doesn't mean wisdom you know the word
for science science eeeh from Latin it
means knowledge and so I think what we
would benefit more from his artificial
wisdom not artificial intelligence and
yet so few people have this wisdom of
course there are people I should I
shouldn't say I don't want you to lose
too much sleep there are people that say
anything that is not forbidden in
science is mandatory in other words if a
law of nature doesn't preclude something
from happening like you know there being
some you know some some force of quantum
mechanics or something
that says you can't go through a wall
well no you actually can go through a
wall if you have certain properties and
if you're a certain size so that happens
all the time so the anything that's not
forbidden is mandatory so some say that
because there's no limit on AI or in the
increase in power of computing etc which
that actually it's already happened hmm
that in other words we've gone through
the singularity we're in the matrix we
just don't recognize it this is called
the simulation hypothesis which is a
fascinating subject I'd love to talk to
you about some other time but but
basically it posits that we are living
in a simulation now and the question of
the computing power because something
could it's not forbidden that we could
go down the route that you just
described that means it's already
happened and actually what we perceive
as reality according to these people the
simulation hypothesis people Nick
Bostrom is the most famous exponent of
it that it's already happened so you
know life's not so bad right now in the
in the if the simulation is true I want
to I want to take it to a different
direction now because I could talk to
you all day but but I have to I have to
ask these questions
because how often do I get a chance to
talk to zubi right so first thing is do
you feel that rappers sometimes from
work against their best interest by you
know not making things that are kids
friendly or not kid friend I don't mean
like mom or whatever just that you you
have to you know put an advisory or a
cautionary thing on does it like did you
do you feel like oh you're less
legitimate because you're not using this
this word of that word where do you come
down and obviously you're a clean
wrapper but that doesn't mean that
necessarily it could be that you're
doing it you know for promotion or for
sales and they increase your base where
do you how do you feel about you know
kind of a rap culture and in the
proliferation of just you know as I said
language in particular as a tool in rap
culture yeah I think you know firstly I
think every single artist and every
single human being will have a different
take on this with me I am I use the same
language in my music that I use in real
in the real world so I don't cuss in
real life if I did cuss in real life I
would probably cuss in my music Yeah
right but I don't cuss in real life so
I'm not going to cuss in my music
because
be fake that would be inauthentic that
would be presenting myself as somebody
and something that I am not so that is
the reason for my music being clean in
terms of not having profanity because I
don't use profanity in everyday life
it's not how I was raised it's not
something I think is is good and
positive nor necessary so that's how it
is for me
ultimately hip-hop rap and every form of
music is a way of an individual
expressing themselves and I'm
essentially a free speech absolutist and
I'm not going to police what people can
and and cannot say in terms of what I
think is good or wholesome or positive
that's a whole different conversation
there's a lot of stuff that is out there
not just in music but out there in the
world which I do not think is good nor
helpful nor positive but it exists and
we you know we have free will we have
free choices we live in relatively free
societies so that comes down very much
to the individual what I would say to
rappers and other people though is um
you know whether or not you want to be a
role model once you reach a certain
level then you are you know it might not
be something that you that you strive
for or something you see yourself as but
you know as I do and I'm not perfect at
it you know by any means but it's
important to think about the impact and
influence that we that we have in the
world and I got into music and rap
because I wanted my words to have an
impact and I wanted my to be able to get
a message across and I wanted to be able
to encourage people and inspire people
and empower people and that's what I
tried to do in my music and everything
else and like I said before you know not
everyone is going to understand it not
everybody's going to like the methods
not everyone's going to like the music
itself not everybody will understand the
message some will interpret misinterpret
it etc that just comes with the
territory but um
yeah ultimately it's it's it's a hard
one it's not something I take a super
strong position on my super strong
position would be on absolutely
defending freedom of speech but that
also includes the right to criticize
things and to say that I don't think
that's good or I don't think that's
wholesome or why are people drawn to
that I think I think I've said this in
an interview before I think a much more
interesting question and why do rappers
and entertainers put out certain types
of content I think a much more
interesting question is why do people
like it so much
mm-hmm right people have a consuming
like oh why are these rappers talking
about violence and drugs and gangs and
why are they disrespecting women etc
it's like why don't you ask the women in
the club who are dancing to it right why
why you ask them why are you just why
are you rapping to this guy calling you
you know referring to women is all these
things I think that's a much more
interesting question not why is the
rapper saying it right well why are you
listening to it and enjoying it and
purchasing it and spending your money on
it and supporting them because you're
going to do that of course they're gonna
keep making it why why would they do
otherwise right they're rational actors
and they're trying to and they're trying
to make money and have a career then it
makes total sense you know my last album
was full of violence and misogyny and
gang banging and drug talk so my second
album is gonna be full of it isn't just
one sold well hey so I think that's a
much more interesting question and that
can go across video games movies any
other type of entertainment as well I
think that's the more interesting
question certainly true and I think back
you know to like what Bach used to put
on all of his music at the top you know
for the greater glory of God and I just
I don't know if ice cube is gonna be
doing we'll see we'll see so I want to
finish up a conversation with I'm gonna
get the questions that I ask all my my
guests that I'm so blessed to have on
the show first thing I though I want to
ask you I got a picture of Oxford your
alma mater in the background zubi
University let's make it
what would kind of courses would zubi
University offer and why oh wow okay
nothing that ends in Studies
everything that ends in studies is gone
so it would have the sort of core
academic disciplines the sciences maths
economics arts music etc certainly the
big things that are totally missing
certainly in school but also largely in
university that I think should
absolutely be in there include physical
health nutrition and fitness that should
absolutely be there
economics finances money management
interpersonal skills public speaking
communication some aspects of
entrepreneurship how to you know
university shouldn't just assume that
everyone wants to get a job should
assume that some people want to create
the jobs some people want to start
businesses some people want to be
entrepreneurs how can someone do what I
do how can how do you build your own
business if you don't just want to go
into the corporate world how else can we
prepare young people for that so those
would be a couple of the key things
because everyone is gonna deal with
money and everyone is going to deal with
health so I think it's somewhat criminal
that there's not more of a priority on
those things in the educational system
yeah that would be an important part of
it yeah it's a message that resonates a
lot with me and of course you know
there's the the value of the classics I
think we all stand on the shoulders of
giants and and there's value in in all
cultures I don't just mean in the
Western civilization I do think that
learning your history if you're ignorant
of your history it's one of the most
grievous lacunae in a person's intellect
and and so yes to your list I would only
add you know just like going deep in the
classics and I have no problem with
different cultures and studying all the
different wonderful contributions up
that I've been made so I think that's
great so I want to move to the questions
that I ask all my guests and the first
one is going to take us into into the
future for you personally morally
ethically etc and that's this notion of
what's called an ethical will in Hebrew
in the name is ah ah ah and it is really
meant to convey that which cannot be
through a monetary or material will
which is sort of like what ethical
teachings what wisdom do you want to
pass on not just to your offspring
hopefully you'll have but but but but
what would you want to pass on to
humanity as a whole in terms of wisdom
as that's immaterial well nothing that
great people haven't said before me love
your neighbor as yourself
truly be kind to people treat people
fairly equally without an unfair
discrimination etc and that should be
that should be really really obvious but
seems like human beings need a constant
reminder of that and then beyond that it
would be recognized that you have
potential and strive to fulfill it
because that will make you better it
will make everyone around you better and
ultimately it will make the world better
if you try to fulfill your own potential
in all different aspects then it gives
you purpose it gives you meaning and it
ultimately helps not just yourself but
it helps collective society so I think
those would be the two big one those
would be the two big ones awesome so our
our podcast of course is called in to
the impossible which is one of arthur c
clarke slaws I'll explain in a second
but but when I want to call your
attention to now is the famous movie
2001 a Space Odyssey where which is
based on Arthur's book of the same name
in that movie there there are scenes
where there are these monoliths there
are these giant structures of black
obelisks or you know some kind of weird
material but are actually machines that
are having placed by some unseen alien
civilization or species so I don't know
how much of a sci-fi and Arab you are
but I'm wondering if zubi could have his
own monolith that he could place in the
solar system as a billion year long time
capsule would what would you put on it
or in it Oh to be about would it have a
message would it have a physical object
what kind of things do you want to put
in the time capsule that could last for
a billion years
whoa maybe I didn't scribe that
ethical will on it okay yeah very good
very good I like that I haven't heard
that one before that's good yeah so the
last one that kind of relates to arthur
c clarke is the relative to the related
to the name of the podcast and one of
Arthur's laws was the only way to
discover the limits of the possible is
to venture a little way past them into
the impossible but I want to ask you is
now we're gonna go back in time we just
went forward in time they're gonna go
back in time what aspect of life you
know seem mysterious maybe even
impossible to use ooby until you went
ahead and did it hmm none of it really
really I mean I'm so ambitious and I
have such high not just expectations but
understandings of what I can possibly
achieve that there's nothing that I do
that I thought was impossible otherwise
I wouldn't have done it so yeah I have I
have a near delusional level of self
belief which some people think is kind
of like cocky or arrogant or whatever
but really it's just understanding my
capabilities and understanding how how
high the ceiling is in reality unless
something is quite literally physically
impossible and it can be achieved yeah
just remember and the laws of quantum
mechanics say if it's not forbidden it's
mandatory Tzipi I want to ask you the
last couple of minutes just the plug
zone anything you want a plug or spin
what's your next book gonna be about
it's gonna be about the body or the mind
I'd ideally like to tie them together
awesome
yeah I can't wait come up with some kind
of I'd love to do some kind of book that
combines aspects of philosophy with
physical fitness with mental fitness and
mindset maybe even with some
socio-political social commentary kind
of stuff in there I don't know I don't
know how if they can all be tied
together but I'd like to tie together
all the
things that make up the zoobi brand and
maybe put out some some interesting book
with some interesting insights on how I
think these things can be things these
things could be connected
now synthesized together well I once
heard the only advice that I heard about
books that I took seriously was only
write a book if you're the only person
who can write the book and I think the
hook you just that you just described
you're uniquely capable of writing and I
want to thank you as you be so much for
spending your time I know you're super
press here so busy doing such great work
I want to thank you I know you don't
like to hear it but for the courage for
your strength for your advice your
strong advice extravaganza and an
inspiring so many people around the
world so zoobi I want you have a
wonderful evening there in the UK and I
hope they get to meet in the
three-dimensional world before we meet
in the major in combination that you
cheat the game of life rap is looking in
my pay then think of cheating on the mic
discuss my one-and-only and she never
leaves me only when I want to beat it
down she's always waiting to be stolen
love like making me so passionate with
metrics bars cannot belittle me a
stylist anorexic that means you think
you're big I hear you talking I'll
address it but you barking never bride
and say you mark is unimpressive my
visions not a dream I'm motivated to
achieve wanna pull facade and I'm
providing it's a leadership any
sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
if you enjoyed this episode of into the
impossible please subscribe comment
share rate and review for a chance to
win a free copy of our most recent guest
newest book send a screenshot of your
review to info at imagine UCSD edu we
appreciate hearing from you and are
always open to your suggestions for
future episodes for more information go
to imagination dot UCSD edu find us on
twitter and imagine UCSD watch us on
youtube listen on itunes into the
impossible is a production of the arthur
c-- clark center for human imagination
in the division of physical sciences at
the University of California San Diego
Eric veeery director Bryan heating Co
director Patrick Coleman associate
director produced by Stewart Valco